la grande barrière de corail au large de
l'australie est malade
les coraux ils dépérissent en plusieurs
endroits à cause du réchauffement de la
mer mais récemment des scientifiques ont
découvert non loin de la grande barrière
une structures sous-marines
spectaculaires bien vivante janvier 2020
le navire de recherche falcor met le cap
sur un monde inconnu pendant près de
douze mois et scientifiques à bord vont
sonder les profondeurs de l'océan au
large de l'australie
au mois d'octobre il faut une découverte
inattendue ou nord-est du pays
un gratte ciel sous marins presque aussi
haut que la tour du cn de toronto se
dresse sur le plancher océanique
il s'agit en fait d'un récif de corail
aux 2 500 m c'est la plus importante
découverte dans la région depuis 120 ans
il s'agit d'un risque distinct de la
grande barrière de corail qui sait dire
un peu plus au sud
grâce à un sonar
l'équipe a esquissé la forme du récif à
sa base le colosse s'étend sur 1,5 km de
large
il atteint son point culminant à 40
mètres sous la surface de l'eau
mon
les chercheurs australiens ont envoyé un
robot sous l'eau pour capter des images
est prélevé des échantillons
ils ont trouvé peu de coraux durs mais
une incroyable l'abondance des ponge et
de corps ou la zone semble riche en
nutriments et le récif est florissant
contrairement à plusieurs endroits dans
la grande barrière de corail où les
coraux montre des signes de
dépérissement
autour du nouveau récif ni scientifiques
ont observé plusieurs espèces de requins
et une grande profusion de poisson
[Musique]
des scientifiques à bord duval corps un
navire de la chouette ocean institute
ont fait plusieurs autres découvertes au
cours de l'année passée en mer dans les
profondeurs de la mer de corail
ils ont repéré deux nouvelles espèces de
coraux loire et des ponts dans les
canyon sous-marin au large de ningaloo
au nord ouest de l'australie
ils ont découvert une trentaine de
nouvelles espèces ils ont aussi observé
la plus longue créatures aussi annick
jamais vu un siphonophore de 45 m cet
invertébré cousins des méduses est formé
de nombreux individus translucide qui
sont reliés par un stolons une espèce de
cordon ombilical
ces découvertes montrent à quel point
les océans qui nous entourent demeure
méconnu et forme d'un monde rempli de
mystères
[Musique]